(Inaudible Screaming) (cringe intro)
What are you insinuating showing cringe clip from me because that does not exist
*reading comment* Stop trynna make cringe Tuesday happen Felix, it's never gonna happen
CRinGE TueSdaY Is HapPeNing
No one stopping cringe Tuesday's it's a thing now.
Every week. Now let's get into the cringe. Cringe time. Let's go.
What is happening?
Is one of those where they just scream like crazy?
Yep!
(Felix Laughing Hysterically)
Look at the judge. (pewd's laughing)
(Lady having a seizure)(pews laughing)
Oh, Please stop
If I'm competing I guess I'm like you can win like oh my god, you're so annoying like Jesus Christ
REEEEEE
Next prey
This one is called bad customer service the manager at this restaurant refused to understand me because I mispronounced the word Entree
the first time I said it he said "what? what is that" then I said it again entry
(pewiepie laughing)
Lol, he said I don't know who that is entry entry
Oh you mean entree?
Yeah, well are you the guy I just spoke to on the microphone? Yeah. Alright. So, uh, how do you pronounce that again?
entree. Okay, entree?
Alright, so like when I asked you the first time when I said it when I said entry to you, You didn't know what it was at all. Right? Entry?
Ya I figured it was entree. Oh, you figured it was entree?
Yeah, cuz it was yeah. "right right like tomato tomahto yeah, that's that's crazy man"
I just need me to order something man, and you don't have to be a smart ass about it, man
(Them talking each other and fighting)
Can I have the entry?
Give me the entry please. He uploaded this thinking you're right. That's amazing.
Twenty four thousand dislikes 150 likes so many delusional people out there that get called out. Thanks to the internet. Thanks in your name
(pewds clapping)
(the men at the restraunt fighting over dumb stuff)
damn damn
What an idiot what a... next cringe. Next cringe time. cringe time. Oh god, I've seen this one. It's amazing
What is his name Piers Morgan, is that his name
So he I don't know if this is real or not because they clearly fake a lot of their
Sketches that he's trying to call out this love island
actress for being stupid and he asked what's the Pythagoras theorem which is a2 plus b2 equals c2
But he confuses it with
PI so he's like, what's the first digits of Pythagoras here, you know Pythagoras theorem to the nearest 5 decimal places, do you?
Oh
God three point four seven. It's certainly the first digits
You don't know the first couple digits of detective clearly. It's easy to mix a mess
it's a
3.14 15 now thank God 3.14 15. Yeah
Tibbs what is your deck name? It flies you guys so so far. I'm really halfway there
It depends on who the you is referring to
Can't you at least chuckle I don't understand what happened there?
WhAT HaPpenED
You fly you dies, it's not that funny either, okay
like come on
It depends on who the you was referring and he's not wrong
It depends on the who than you is referring to maybe she dies. Maybe you dies. That was a joke
could you laugh, please just laugh
Kind of want him to just throw a fit just go like, you know if you your jokes sucked. Okay, I don't need you
And in accordance with God's will you do now confession we're still good
Please sirs leave. Oh, please
Anywhere other than here
This is a solemn assembly not a photography
Please move
Or I will stop
oh
I will stop the ceremony if you do not get out of the way
This is not about god damn it, he's a photographer he's supposed to take photos. Oh man
This is my nightmare me - - getting married. This happens. Goddamn. It's two of the idiots out there. There's just too many idiots
The teacher was hiding as a student and he thought he would be slick
Ah, that's so great
Oooh no
Oh wow that's so cool wow
Look at him He was a teacher all along
I would keep the cyberbullying
Keep it keep the cyberbullying. I mean the best advice I would keep the cyber bullying
Yeah, what do you got?
Tell the cyber bullies
That's right bullies, ok, I'm sorry haters. I'm so sorry
Cyber bullying just say something
sdgadsgnbvnjcdbfgk
It's like something wants to leave your body for the record I get it. standing in front of a crowd
Getting stuck getting nervous your body freezes up
You're stuck and you can't think everyone's been there in a while except me. That's right
Angry Wednesday coming up tomorrow. You better look forward to it cuz I am getting ANGRY
All right, what is this algae. Chloe what's for dinner tonight?
This is reason
Chloe, come on. Okay. Chloe is not gonna talk to me. Chloe doesn't like me evidently Chloe
Am I ready on my wash rinse cycle?
Wow Chloe seems like such a great product
Even robots have bad days. No, no no fix your goddamned stupid voice-recognition BS
Okay, and stop selling us the advices god. Damn
I'm so glad that happened because that's how it is when you buy an Alexa or whatever
ALexA hbfjhksfn
That's how it is like okay, I just saved you 40 pounds. You're welcome
Okay, it's a woman shanks ball golf ball into crowd twice
Jesus!
That's gotta hurt
But you're not gonna apologize at least check if they're all right Jesus you could kill someone how are they still standing there
Go away. Oh no
Don't do it. Oh my god.
make her stop!
Oh, Gosh I can't even. Ah
Stop just stop Golfing
Yeah everyone backup this woman is crazy
This is what I've been saying all along women not golf I say it and they don't listen some guy in the crowd laughter
Jesus Christ what a Savage that guy must be watching cringe Tuesday's am I right?
Smash like if you wan't another episode of cringe Tuesday's doesn't matter because it's coming up. Anyway, Cringe Tuesdays. It's a thing
Thank you guys for watching Cringe Tuesday. I'm gonna go lay down. I have a little nap and maybe then I feel better
Thank you guys. Bye. Bye
What! Tuber simulators becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please sponsor Eagle, please do something!
Yes!!
Y E H E H A H A
A H H H H
This game is still relevant god damn it!
Thank You to all of the people creating subtitles!